[موسيقى]
الجنوب الفرنسي في سبعينيات القرن الماضي
كان مصدر الهام مصمم الازياء اللبناني
زهير مراد لربيع وصيف هذا العام في
الخياطه الرفيعه
فعاكس ذلك اسلوب عيش نبلاء فرنسا الذين
كان البعض منهم من يسكن الريفيرا الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
السبعينات شفت صورك كتير وقف افلام هيك
كثير عطتني مود كثير حلو
مود او لايف ستايل حياه كان كله اذا بدك
هابينس وبيس
وهيك سيلبريشن بالحياه وحفلات وعشوات
وسنسد بارتيز وسهرات ما بتنتهي
وبنات حلوين اذا بدك من البحر مشط البحر
لا يمكن لما يطلعوا على البسكلات
كثير اساس حلو في الصور كتير
[موسيقى]
الحرير والتين شكلت اقمشه مجموعه مراد اما
حياكه التطريز على قطع المجموعه فقد
استوحاها مصممها من الهندسه المعماريه
لبيوت ريفيرا الفرنسيه التي اشتهرت
بزخارفها المميزه كما شهدت تطريز المحرم
والتطريز بالتقنيه
فرنجستون
بامتياز الوان
الاصفر والازرق الخفيف وكذلك اللون الذهبي
لحظات الهروب
[موسيقى]
عن جد عرض رائع بكل يعني الفايبس اللي فيه
حبيت انه بلش العرض باللون الابيض كانه
رساله سلام بوقت اللي نحن بهال
يعنيرجي مثل هاي حبيت التاتش الفينتاج
اللي بتشوفها كمان بالشغل شغله ثقيله
اليوم كنت عم شوف مجوهرات بالرانويه اكثر
من انه
عن جد شبوبه
نجاح الراس وربطه العنق والقبعات المحاكم
من الاحجار الكريمه والمريخ الملون شكلت
اكسسوارات العرض وغابت الحقائب عن مجموعه
زهير مراد هذا الموسم لاظهار سيده حره
بعيده عما يقيدها
[موسيقى]
زهير بيعرف يعمل الموشن
وانا كثير فخوره
[موسيقى]